wolfie's on tick tock just dancing
by the way i went down the tick tock
hole i can't offer you daddy
yeah but it's so it's so hypnotic yeah
i'm watching
fighting and i'm watching dancing not
for you and i'm and i'm just like i keep
going
you're too old
people are singing they're 16. no
they're they're adults yeah because
they do different things majority of
them
very young no i'm i'm watching either
the fight i know what you're watching or
i'm watching
the dancing i'm not the girls and the
dancer hip-hop
you're the hip-hop dancer you like the
movie not young you know he's interested
in hip-hop because everybody
everybody doesn't dance with the same
song and i'm like there's a trend yeah
get off tick tock though for me
it's not my fault i'm on instagram and
then you find yourself on the tick tock
oh that's reals you're on the internet
yeah that's yeah that's what it is i'm
doing it
i don't have time i don't have tic tac
you keep it's like it's it's so it's
like eye candy yeah
tick tock below is now in days parkour
just sucks because it just works against
every
it just works for people like addison
ray it just works for the girls who do
nothing but the stupid tick tock dancer
so like the rest isn't good
yeah you can look it's watching reels
what's the some of the memories some of
it says tit talk
educated so yeah that's what i do like i
i like if
one of my tick tocks i like i put like a
lot of work into doesn't blow up i'm
like [ __ ] this
i'll save it to my phone and then i'll
upload it real quick
better there sometimes yeah because i
get reels on fire in the kit or mine
i do fighter kid reels
i don't dance anymore uh but i'm not i
will do the same thing as ryan where i
am on the instagram reels and people
will repost their tickets
got it here's what brian did if i'm
being honest yeah what do you do a hotel
room in
toledo or at the outskirts not at all
holiday inn
no i was at the uh uh red roof hilton uh
homes
suites the home number two sweets
yeah and um
go on what did you do did daddy rent
some porn on tv no no i didn't do that
no doesn't that's an old band move yeah
didn't do it
can't watch porn doesn't do it for me
however i
i took a little online tutorial
in hip-hop
that's why i had nothing else to do let
me see if i still got it
i'm blushing and i went we've never had
it yeah never
can we see some of your moves and i was
like i was doing this with my
heels and i was so bored out there and i
i was trying to do the moonwalk and i
was like
oh the movie well this is all too
[ __ ] difficult
and i just it's my time has passed what
i love about you you just try
i try to just try it i don't go for it
did you i [ __ ] love it i was like
maybe i'll start hip hop dancing yeah
that'd be sick would you give it a shot
you would have never known what you may
as well maybe go get my black button
yeah i'll see you in 10 years and it's
still not going to happen
but you give it us what what old video
was watching
i was trying to do it did you standing
how much did you have after you got out
of that i was sitting i was doing this
look alone
and and i put on my shoes and i was
doing and then my knee kind of
tweaked a little and i was like this is
the i have to talk about this the move
is tough i sat down like this and then
stared at my screen to write nothing
happened
it's tough when i'm writing when i'm
trying to write i will do weird [ __ ]
i'll i'll go down the i don't do the hip
hop anymore